uh so first we'll put that question out
again so do you train ambidextrously
with the knives and the answer is yes
but I like to carry my knives in two
different
directions um so it's not that I have
I'll put my knife in my left pocket and
then I'll put it in the right pocket so
my hold is usually one on support side
and then one in the center Center Line
uh going down so is it different okay
that way in the center line one I have
my right hand available for that one but
if I can't get to my pocket my left hand
can also draw it too and then as I said
uh you can also carry the Scout a scout
hold on the back so you have that one um
and then lastly when I'm on duty I have
pens that double as spikes okay um then
the other thing that we're talking about
here is or or what that allows you to do
is you don't have to pick a technique
that gets you to your weapon you now can
work any technique and you go to the
weapon that that technique opens for you
okay so today we're just going to work
with support side okay for me and you
guys will work uh strong side if your
right handed so you'll work that right
pocket okay if you have a
shirt you're going to have to do a
two-handed move which is going to take
away from some of this okay okay but if
sometimes if you're wearing like a long
shirt uh it'll Jack it up if you try to
do that so you'll always be faster by
grabbing the shirt and exaggeratedly
pulling that thing up cuz under stress a
little is never enough so you pull it up
and then you would draw the weapon okay
got it there's two moose okay which
again you're going to have to generate
space and time for that and angle for
that because two hands are going to be
occupied on the draw stroke okay
any other questions on
this okay
uh when it comes to
weapons uh you have to deal with
retention issues and the best way of
dealing with retention issues is uh
being out of range that would cause them
and that's where your iido Kona is so
it's all
assuming that you have a weapon all the
the Tactical spectrum of waza is
assuming you have weapons on you okay um
and so this drill you'll see uh is
probably going to open itself up more to
your iido Kon waza uh than some of the
other live training environments that we
use okay so um let's just say uh I'll
demonstrate that now so he he'll do some
sort of Ambush attack and make it kind
of aggressive okay they make it kind of
aggressive I don't want to try and draw
this weapon from in here you see it's
not that I can't but it's very risky
that I could get disarmed here okay so
instead right I can use my technique and
then I now have my drawability and he
gets to decide whether he wants to come
in like that or not but I've greatly
increased my advantage without any risk
if we're here
and I draw my weapon and he oh crap and
now you see now now we're we're battling
over weapon retention
okay so again as he's coming in I don't
want to try to do
that I want to always
project drop and
and we're in
okay you have your two basic techniques
external and internal distance
creation
so external line is that I
move I move pull and
draw and the internal one is a
projection and now you have your
distance okay uh so let's deal with that
the guy will grab will start close be
quite aggressive and of course you can
mix external and internal okay get out
of grappling range and back to weapon
deployment range here we
[Music]
go
explode come on so I don't wear it there
wear it back here at the
end you got to get it out dude
and
break don't go for it until he's going
away from
you pull it
forward
so see that that that that little uh y
yangong at the end it was fine but the
little Yong Yong at the beginning not
fine there you
go
balance
man try to always go forward not
[Music]
backwards
there you
go
[Music]
okay here
go notice how I go forward on the spiral
did you see see that so I don't want to
go
backwards I'm going to go forward on the
spiral on the
spiral
he
goes
shielding this is why it's important to
have knives on all around your body so
he's being very
aggressive but if I'm on the back side
of my body shielding with the front I
won't run into those retention issues
okay as opposed to I'm on the front side
and I try to draw I'll run into it so I
have to wait for
it
so hips
forward
shielding he goes
attending
distance
deviation
attendi don't let people run at you for
free got it
so what was was the first
one okay
filum I know there was a right cross and
I know there was a strike in there okay
so that will help you where you're not
here and you're trying to throw
someone you kind of hit boom he goes
again boom again boom again and then you
can get it no one closes the gap for
free all right let's go
okay
good good find where you can
Shield headlock escapes
man can't shield shield it
Shield it there it is there it
is
good
[Music]
you're Y yanging Man try to Shield try
to
Shield there you go two but you yeah
there you go good shielding
see if you can Shield
there
good all
right
okay partial partial
deployment
okay so when you have the ring here your
your ring can hit on the ribs it can cut
on the face okay cut on the face uh hit
on the head so don't freak out if your
knife doesn't open all the way okay so
you still have the ring in there uh the
other thing you have if you have the
wave
technology you the guy's grappling on
you and you got it out you can't open it
on him okay so you'll just hook it
anywhere on him and you you'll open your
knife okay as don't don't go back to
uh trying to open it with two
hands you know what I mean don't don't
don't try to flip it it's not sure you
just put it anywhere on him drag it
across his body and it'll open up
okay got it okay so partial openings
don't freak out that's why you have that
wave on there okay
try
try to Shield if you're tied up try to
Shield
good watch the young young good
shielding
though
remember your spiraling footworks don't
go backwards take them on the
spiral good
Shield
arm
drag Shield good use it on him
good yep anywhere just hook it
[Music]
yes
arm
drag good there you
go look for that arm drag more
again good Chris arm
drag arm
drag good Let Go yep
Shield a telli would have been
nice okay so all that's external okay it
gets much easier when you're internal
internal do you see how much more
struggling have to do externally
okay and that's the beauty of the
internal you don't have to deviate as
much
can you guys see that
okay try it it's going to be to
okay
look to project
[Music]
good
good well that's the downside of a
Grappler is he he wants the slow
approach so he can't be thrown but now
the knife's openable
okay good good good good use of the
Ring
okay pull forward in the
pocket
too far away too far away if you're that
far away he'd just draw them draw the
knife first
okay we
chilling but we're we're here we're want
to see the internal we want to see the
cou pro
[Music]
ejection look for the shield I don't
know what happened why are we
quitting you all
right forward did you get it out yeah
use him
that's the external push you can't you
can't Project without your feet
grounding okay so uh
Tristan no no no I want you to pay
attention I can use R and I might use
one of you others too so you could feel
what's going on okay so and this this is
why um your internal and your external
are combined in
iido you you're supposed to reconcile
the two of them that they're contained
in each other okay but when it comes to
learning and
training if you slowly rely on the
external it it'll almost negate your
internal okay so uh if he starts coming
in and I'm like moving my feet moving my
feet moving my feet I can never get the
Earth rebounding energy going do do you
understand okay so it's again it's not
that I can't I have to keep my feet
still to do
it but when I'm walking I have to
ground ground you see I can't I can't
just be I can't be still in such a
dynamic situation to get a
projection but I can't be running around
and never grounding okay so even as I as
we're moving moving moving moving
moving I can still find the ground on
whichever foot I can and then you can
get the projection then you get the
distance okay so what was happening to
you which is not it's not bad it it
works works you get it like you know be
here you're trying to do different moves
it'll
work right yeah okay it'll it'll work
you get it but it starts to work less
the stronger he is the faster he is the
more skilled he is you get what's
happening okay so you want to move
you're moving but you're
always
uh being able to ground and get get that
rebounding energy okay got it do you
guys see that okay um I
usein so that's the C on the I part is
when she comes remember she's going to
touch something and I want to touch back
I don't care what it is okay so um you
know even if I go she goes and I see the
opening
boom okay cool but we wanted to try and
move we did the atmi stuff already and
now we're trying to do the internal
stuff so you're going to reach for
whatever I'm not going to shove for good
form so she kind of compressed me here
you see and on this side I have this
head I have the inside of the arm here
and we'll turn the other way so camera
can see and and I have this part of my
forearm and my elbow and here and those
things are are sticking on her you think
you get it so now now she pushes and now
I'm trying that footwork around and but
I'm sticking to her so I'm
sticking got got it so I saw you guys
reaching out but just like your footwork
was external your hand work was external
too and it's just like ah it's not going
to work okay so right when she starts
you're you're already stuck okay she's
going to resist she's going to ground
and do whatever not lose her balance it
doesn't matter okay but you have to do
that so as fast as she goes you stick
however it is so I have friction on the
outside hip here behind the arm here and
I stick okay there we do that again pull
up and it's enough to get the projection
out okay do you guys understand that so
you
can't go she goes in your here cuz this
is an external thing you see and I don't
you you're much more maneuverable around
here you see that but instead right on
contact there stuck you feel it
okay same thing whatever stuck stuck
stuck
whatever stop stop so stay there here
here right here here on the stomach here
on the head here on the chin and here on
the arm and
together those things stick doesn't
matter where okay that'll help you get
what you want I think if you don't feel
the stickiness you go into panic mode
and now you go external cuz external is
ego triarte
mind so you fear trigger Z go triarte
mind you go external and you're reduced
to just external Yin yelds and things
like that okay all right so let's try
they grab and you stick no no more knife
stuff just see if you can stick on
initial contact okay
let's